la zoneix en un mot la guerre de tous
contre tous je dirais la bagarre
physique tout simplement bah ça se
[Musique]
voit connaître certains c'est un
avantage quand même surtout ceux qui
aiment pas trop parler quand on a
l'habitude de les rencontrer à l'année
dans les clubs ça permet quand même
d'avoir des des des moments privilégiés
après c'est l'art du placement il faut
être là le premier faut savoir jouer des
cou pour être au premier rang pour
atteindre le joueur avoir de de longom
bras pouir infiltrer mettre son
téléphone pas être trop devant pas être
trop derrière ça c'est c'est très
important stratégique souvent les
joueurs quand ils s'arrêtent au début
ils s'arrêtent plus donc tu es un peu
obligé parfois de jouer les coudes et de
d'Er directement voir les joueurs bien
en tête quoi faut pas il faut pas
hésiter savoir faire des sourires aussi
aux gens de la cafe pour qu'il t'apporte
un joueur même parfois quand on a la
bonne place on n pas forcément la bonne
réaction des joueurs parfois qui ceux
qui qui ont perdu n'ont souvent pas
envie de
parler le plus dur c'est l'attente on
attend souvent 45 minutes 1 heure voir
plus et des fois pour rien bah vous avez
trois positions soit vous attendez comme
ça soit la position défétistes
sinon vous tournez le dos à la porte le
plus dur c'est de les coincer justement
quand ils ont déjà répondu à 50
journalistes avant toi c'està dire quand
on est au fond c'est mort on peut plus
avoir de de de réaction ça c'est le pire
et surtout quand les joueurs ont perdu
pire moment de la zone mix ceux qui
jouent des coutes avec toi y compris
pendant les interviews qui peut être des
stabilisant le cadre qui se dérobe le
micro qui part parfois c'est vrai que le
joueur sur le terrain il moule le
maillot et tout mais nous aussi on moule
le maillot donc on aimerait parfois que
les joueurs s'arrêtent qu'il nous
fassent plaisir parce que on est là pour
eux on est là pour donner au football
toute sa grandeur et voilà quoi
[Musique]
merci